let's go back to 10 years old 12 years
old everybody has an influence right for
me my mother's family they were all
Communists my dad's family they were
imperialists for you to be this much of
a True Believer what was the
conversations like at the kitchen table
with Mom and Dad what did you guys talk
about
well there was full mobilization in the
Cold War across the country but
particularly places like Texas uh and uh
in the South and so I mean I would go to
family reunions and it was like a
soldier of fortune convention uh and so
uh a lot of the family had been you know
obviously in World War II Korea Vietnam
and a lot of them had been um you know
operatives in the CIA and things like
that but to me you're a kid and when the
family reunion's going on you know I'm
just uh you know getting a four-wheeler
and you know taking a shotgun off and
shooting birds I'm not you know hanging
out with all these old men and then a
lot of family on my dad's side that had
done stuff for the government uh in
operations not just around the world but
here because back then it was all human
intelligence by the 90s it went to
digital stuff but before that you had to
have a lot of muscle on the ground a lot
of people people that don't know the
Army you know all over the world but
also in the US would go around you know
killed people it was like extrajudicial
Senators would sign off on letters and
they would and then they said well
usually army officers off to kill people
so like when you see the movie
um uh well what's that movie with uh all
the great actors uh Apocalypse Now where
he you know they have the Army captain
and then they're sending them to Kill
Colonel Kurtz that's a fictional story
but that's actually how it works the
biggest Hitman group in in the United
States or the world would be like army
officers like that sick like oh the
Italian mafia's got a hundred Hitman
well they've got ten thousand so and and
then my uh I had well my dad had a guy
called you know like his uncle was
released a cousin 10 years older that
lived across the street and he only told
my dad about this later and stuff but
that was one of his jobs and then my
mom's uh brother I've been an army
officer and uh he was involved in Iran
Contra a bunch of Black Ops but he was
involved in like being in charge of
things building airfields in Central and
South America uh and so he was the one
that really told me about all this stuff
and then and then my dad
had got recruited into the academic arm
of the stuff uh in it was it was like
above the CIA in like plan two at
University of Texas when he was like 14
15. he was already going to University
of Texas because he was he because he
was winning all these Awards and had top
you know perfect score and uh his mom
thought he was going to when he was like
14 to get to take tests of being NASA in
this and and Eisenhower's whiz kid
program but it wasn't Eisenhower it
wasn't a whiz kids program to be in NASA
and so my dad got into that for a while
he never told me what he did and they
decided like to get out of it and just
be a doctor at a certain point uh but he
the house was just full of all this big
Brzezinski books and Henry Kissinger
stuff and just World politics and you
know just military manuals and just
stuff everywhere and my dad was just
always racist reading and so I just grew
up basically around all this stuff and
it was particularly my mom's
um brother who died about nine years ago
really smart guy uh who uh got out of it
and uh and then when he was
dying of pneumonia last time I saw him I
thought he was gonna live and he was
dead a week later
um he just said well I want you to know
the stuff about them trafficking kids is
true and that's why I got out of what I
was doing in Central America uh because
uh you know they were they were
smuggling kids out of orphanages and
doing terrible things with them and we
just knew about your this is your mom's
brother my mom's brother and of course
remember this is nine years ago before
all the migrant crisis the kids and the
current smuggling he was seeing it down
there and he said he and a bunch of his
guys uh got out of it uh some of the
guys he was with the government killed
and what was his background your uncle
uh he was a helicopter pilot in Vietnam
and uh and mainly delivered Special
Forces troops into Laos and places and
he worked for him you know he uh my mom
doesn't like me telling this stuff
because he told her about it didn't tell
me and she says you know it's
embarrassing the family but you know he
uh I mean he was doing whatever he's
told Vietnam and it was it was it was
smuggling your opium your mom and dad
when they saw you when you first got
into you've been in the space of in four
Wars in which you've been known for how
long 30 years 28 years 25 years 29 years
29 years okay
so when you first got in I was 20 years
old you were 20 years old okay so what
was their initial reaction to was it
like Alex what are you doing and there
was a we we believe in you we agree with
you you're talking too much but relax
this is you're going overboard what was
their reaction to this when you first
got started uh my dad for the first five
six seven years was just sometimes say
you need to be careful what you're doing
and you're you could get killed doing
this he said one time he said I could
have you talk to some people and get you
out of this right now but he said I said
the government's bad he said they are
bad they got to do bad things to protect
this country they're in charge because
they're smart and and they're smarter
than us what a thing to say and and yeah
yeah they got to do bad things to
protect the country yeah and and well
you know because there's bad guys and so
we have totally get it yeah yeah we get
it and we have to fill the place in the
bad guys so they don't control that
space
okay we gotta fill the space of the bad
guys so they don't control that space
yes that's also began to brazinski
Harvard's you know uh straussian uh in
justifies the main stuff this is the
really the philosophy there but but
they're really the bad guys and then
about six years into it my dad came and
apologized he said no you're right and
and then and then and because the system
wasn't that bad you know it's on the
surface 25 years ago yeah but but then
he was no you're right and like his uh
his cousin you know would do stuff like
I'd be over there for coffee like once
or twice a year ago yeah I've been
reading some of the stuff you're doing
you better be careful they're gonna kill
your ass and I don't even know at that
time that's what he did I mean I'm
sitting there with an army officer that
you know so so let me let me I'm trying
to get the dates right here because so
29 years ago uh makes it uh 1996. is it
is it fair to say you started in 1990 no
no I started in uh 94 94. okay so and
Wikipedia is all wrong 29 years ago
Wikipedia is all wrong it says info was
trying to
2019. that's just the way the internet
registers it once I transferred it it
started in 1997 I got the website
perfect so 1994 you get started six
years later your dad is saying you're
right is this pre you saying what's
going to happen to the towers or what's
going to happen there's an attack that's
gonna happen in July was it pre-dat
event or did your dad say I agree with
what you're doing post that event now he
said he agreed with me right before that
so pre-911 he agreed with you yes and
then what did he say to you after 9 11
when you're like that this is what's
going to happen I I'm assuming you're
talking to your mom and dad and like
Alex you sure about this you just made a
that's a pretty outlandish claim you're
making and then boom 911 happens what's
that immediate conversation like with
the re and the reason why I want to
focus on parents is because my influence
is my mom and dad so it's kind of like
there's as you're as you're making these
types of claims unless you say you're on
a crusade I think you in your mind you
think you're on a crusade right that's
right you can't trust a lot of people
there's only a few people you can trust
they can let your guards down and just
talk to them I would assume your Mom and
Dad aren't that uh in that oh yeah they
were always good people they weren't
villains and and but my mom you know you
know has you know a degree in history
they were just always into this stuff
and they believed in America and it's
like a naiveness that well we do some
bad things because you know we've gotta
you know beat the bad guys so they were
more from the standpoint of Alex you got
a million other things you can do you're
smart why are you doing this this is not
the life you want to live is it kind of
like that message or no uh it was it was
we don't want you to get killed I mean
they knew I mean they knew
they're like look you're young and and
yeah the system's bad we you know people
try to work in it to fix it and you need
to be really I mean it was mainly you
just need to be careful so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign